[Music]
hello friends welcome once again to our
program i'd like to know
i'm daniel miranda and i'm here with the
company of
pastor c.a murray associate speaker for
secrets and seal welcome pastor thank
you good to be here and also thank you
for joining us in this program is one of
our favorite programs because we can
interact with you
we can know the questions that you have
so it's good to hear from you all
in the different questions that you send
us
if you want to send in your questions
please do it so at this following email
tv
sumtv.org again this is tv at some
tv.org
we can
receive your questions and we will try
to answer them in the order that we
receive them
we have
a great amount of questions
so we will try to do our best and we
like to spend our time in some questions
because we believe
they are important many others have
these questions as well
before we begin i would like to ask
pastor c murray to please
pray for us
before we open the word of god
gracious father again we thank you for
the privilege of studying your word we
thank you that we have confidence and
can indeed have confidence in your word
as a lamb to our feet and a light unto
our path yes that for
areas of practice and doctrine and truth
and drawing closer to you your word is
powerful
quicker than any two-edged sword and it
shows us and instruct us on the way we
ought to live
so father again we ask you to surround
this program with your love and your
grace
be the center and circumference of this
particular broadcast and may it go out
into the world to teach men and women
that jesus is coming soon
and to prepare them for that day in
jesus name amen amen amen
okay we have a question from
k basinger
and
this question
has to do
with gog and magog
the person wants to know
what or who
is gog
and magog
all right good question um
let's let's look at a couple places
where this terminology is used um
the one that jumped out at me first is
revelation of course 20 verse 8. it's
also in ezekiel 38 verse 2 in the old
testament but let's look at 20
verse 8 and
just read that it's it's not long
uh
in fact let's go
back to verse 7
so that we'll start not starting it in
the middle of thought now when the
thousand years have expired
so we know we're dealing with
post-millennial theology here
satan will be released from his prison
and of course that prison is a prison of
circumstances he is not
jailed per se
he is in prison because there's simply
no one left for him to
uh to tempt
all right and we'll go out to deceive
the nations which are in the four
corners of the earth
gog and magog
to gather them together
to battle
whose number is as the sand of the sea
so
that is a good place to go
of the book of revelation as you read in
chapter 20
gives us a prophecy of
gog and magog who
surround the city of god
and
actually satan gathers
gog magog to battle against god and
those who are in the city and as you
said
the first reference that we find in the
bible
about gog and magog is in ezekiel 38
and 39
and the book of revelation borrows this
imagery of gaga magog to talk about the
final
battle
the armageddon
between good and evil
now some people
some good intention christians
they have understood gog and magog as a
as russia
for example in ezekiel 38
verse 1 and 2 we read from the new king
james version now the word of the lord
came to me saying
son of man
set your face against gog
in the land of magog
the prince of rush
so some people say rush that's
russia and
magog does moscow
meshech
and tubal
and prophesy
against
him
now in order to understand what gog and
magog is
in in the new testament we need to
understand gog and magog in the altar in
the old testament they are simply
nations and kings
that are enemies of god's people
they want to attack god's people
there is a
an alliance here predicted by prophet
ezekiel
that is going to be formed to
attack
god's people but we had mentioned in a
previous program
that these prophecies of the old
testament
they have a nature
a characteristic a particular
characteristic and is that they're
classical prophecies and because they're
classical prophecies
they are conditional
this prophecy of ezekiel 38 and 39
was never fulfilled
why
we don't have at least a record of this
battle
of israel against gog and magog we don't
have this battle
but
what's the reason because
the condition for the fulfillment of
this prophecy which is ezekiel 36 and 37
in ezekiel 36 we see the renewal of the
covenant
the new covenant god promises to write
his law in their hearts and to pour out
his spirit upon all flesh
so that they can walk in their statues
in ezekiel 37 again we see a revival
we see the the dry bones leave a
reference to every bible among god's
people
since these conditions were not
fulfilled
then
the war
in ezekiel 38 and 39 did not happen
paul says all who live godly lives shall
suffer persecution but that they didn't
suffer persecution from gog and magog
because they were not living
holy life
so
now that doesn't mean that then the
bible is false or ezekiel was a false
prophet but now these
portions of scripture
take a
scathological cosmic
perspective
and
the revelator in revelation uses gog and
magog
with the same significance as enemies of
god's people yes but they are not
referring specifically to a nation
russia in this case
because we know after the millennium
there won't be any nations i mean there
will be that's the key i knew we're
going to get there
we know that uh this wicked one the
people that resurrect and satan gathers
them there are people from all ages yes
so all this
huge company as the sand of the sea as
we read here
they all represent gog and magog yes yes
well said daniel um and and i co-signed
that totally i don't really have much to
add
say for the fact that the last point
that you raised is significant one that
after the millennium
nations as we know them simply will not
exist exactly
there
there won't be any governmental
structure
there is a marshaling of forces under
satan
to attack the city but there is no there
is no governmental structure so it could
not be russia or any any government set
up by this earth uh because they simply
won't exist so we're talking about an
entity a group of people who represent a
classic enemy of god's people yes uh and
and really
john drew from many many and you find
this over and over again in revelation
many many
existing old testament examples right to
to explain uh or to give light on what
he was talking about so
if you're trying to identify a specific
nation you can't do that because none
exists so he's just using the example of
classic of a classic system against god
to um
to represent this group of people who
are bent on the destruction of
god's sable and the taking of the
heavenly city yes yes yes
well done uh
good good question
uh because um gog and magov has occasion
some questions in uh these last days all
right what do we have next
we're going to hold this one next we
have uh signo
iroka or wai roqua
and
actually he introduces himself as carlos
and he is uh 1720. addressing you
personally pastor ca
he says hello ca i'm carlos
can you ex please explain luke 17 verses
20 and 21. yes now i've taken this one
and i have not i've not looked at looked
at this
question
i guess i will look at it now
now when he was asked by the pharisees
when the kingdom of god would come he
answered them and said the kingdom of
god does not come with observation yes
nor will they say
see here or see there for indeed the
kingdom of god is within you um
he wants 20 and 21 and that's 20 and 21.
um it's a good question
christ
preached among other things that the
kingdom of god was at hand
and he actually
this text is almost self-explanatory yes
because he is not saying
go to
fresno
and the kingdom of god is there
uh go to clovis the kingdom of god is
there christ came to let men and women
know that the kingdom of god is is in
you yeah you know we we have that
wonderful text and
ages playing games with me here let this
mind be in you which is also in christ
jesus that's the entrance of the kingdom
of god
um
we we quoted in the last text there's
now no condemnation for those who are in
christ jesus then you've got the famous
set of texts in john chapter 15 verse 5
uh and on where christ is asking uh and
and giving us counsel to allow him to
abide in us
these are all examples of the existence
of the kingdom of god yes that the
kingdom of god is is is you know when
when christ the jews accused him accused
him of kingdom building and and being a
threat to kingdom to to rome uh his
answer was my kingdom is not of this
world yes so i'm not here to do anything
with with with the romans we find in
john chapter six it's around about verse
after the feeding of the 5000 they
wanted to make him king you know um
interesting enough by the end of that
chapter uh verse 66 the bible says many
of them walked back with turned back and
walked no more with him because because
precisely because he wasn't trying to
set up an earthquake exactly so they
didn't want any part of him uh so the
burden uh daniel as you well know of
christ was to let them know that i am
going to be your god but i will do that
by setting up my kingdom in your heart i
will place myself on the throne of your
heart not in any particular place but
command you
oh well said pastor ca
you know
for some people it's not clear the
difference between the kingdom of grace
and the kingdom of glory and actually
this question gives us a a context for
the next question that we have
um
and
these two questions i'm sure they were
not in agreement when they sent them but
the king you know jesus
spoke about the kingdom of god many
times in his parables the kingdom of god
is liking unto this yeah kingdom of god
is liking unto that
and in all those parables most of them
jesus makes a reference to a hard work
the kingdom of god he makes reference to
a spiritual nature of the kingdom of god
as you said
the kingdom of grace
was instituted
in eden when sin entered
and was established at the cross when
jesus died but then the kingdom of glory
will
is instituted when jesus enters into the
most holy place to receive the kingdom
from his father
and will be established at the second
coming of jesus christ so
the jews confused
the what the prophecies that pointed to
the kingdom of glory yes with the
kingdom of grace and that's why they
believed that jesus was going to come
and set up an earthly kingdom
but that was what that's what he was
going to do in his second coming yes but
jesus first came
to establish a kingdom of grace that
begins
in your heart before having
the earthly kingdom which we know that
we will inherit after the millennium yes
the earth may knew we need to have that
kingdom in our hearts yes yes well said
um you know you
this thing was so thoroughly entrenched
in jewish culture and mind
set that even john the baptist even
christ highlighted as the the greatest
born of woman
had it wrong you know it was you know
you have something that's repeated in
your mind in your mind i hear many times
you're watching television or you're
looking at some sporting event and
someone will say uh well she's looking
down he's looking down and he was
looking over me and and i know that
they're watching from heaven well that's
that's that's not bible that's popular
culture correct and and and is not
biblically substantiated well you had
the same kind of thing in in in jewish
history they had so long suffered
under the chastening hand of the roman
empire that their
kingdom of glory kingdom of grace became
confused and conflated and they were
looking for freedom from rome and christ
didn't come to give him that such that
when there were many who understood as i
alluded to in john chapter 6 that christ
was not coming to overthrow rome well i
don't want him part of that i didn't
sign up for that i certainly didn't sign
up for suffering i signed up for glory
not grace so they didn't want that but
even john the baptist blesses heart
didn't have it right because it was such
a part of popular culture in that day
yeah good question good answer
thank you carlos
i'm wondering how seno
who ah
raqqa becomes carlos i'd like to know
carlos if you are of a mindset write us
again and and let us know how how we
work our way through that but i'm glad
you sent in the question
uh good question and uh we thank you for
it all right very good so we we go to
the next question
michael bruce i think we have already
received some questions before from our
dear brother michael thank you for
writing us
and this question again comes from
daniel 2 44.
um i remember last questions were also
from daniel 2 and daniel 6 yes yes and
it says here this quotation by ellen
white leads me to believe
that the kingdom of daniel 2 44 has
already been set up at the cross
and then later
he now he quotes from letter 32
through the hebrew captives
that's daniel and his friends
the lord was to make was
the lord was made known to the hidden in
babylon
this idolatrous idolatrous nation was
given a knowledge of the kingdom
the lord was to establish
and through his power maintained against
all the power
and craft
of satan
so his question is the quote sounds like
is as if god had already set up that
kingdom
and those and was fighting against the
craft of satan and if those these two
kingdoms are going to exist
contemporaneously
okay
so he wants our thoughts on this
well as we said in the previous
questions
we need to understand the nature of the
kingdom of god so if we go to the verse
that our daniel mike our brother michael
is
quoting which is daniel 2 44 before we
interpret the spirit of prophecy we need
to go to the bible
itself yeah the bible itself is clear
enough to give us answers
to those questions daniel 2 44.
in this portion here daniel is giving
the interpretation of the dream of the
king
and now he's going to interpret the rock
and these in
in the days of these kings
the god of heaven will set up a kingdom
which shall never be destroyed and the
kingdom shall not be left to other
people it shall break in pieces and
consume all these kingdoms
and it shall stand
for
ever
so
um
clearly
the setting up of this kingdom
is referring to the rock
that was cut out actually here in verse
45 it says in as much as you saw that
the stone was cut out of the mountain
without hands that is with human without
human intervention right
and and it broke in pieces the iron the
bronze the clay the silver and the gold
the great god has made
known to the king what will come to pass
after this so this is clear future the
dream is certain and its interpretation
is sure
sure
so
clearly this is pointing to
the kingdom of glory that god is going
to establish now the quote says that
through his power
maintain against all the power of kratos
satan we we we mentioned that before god
establishes the kingdom of glory
as satan in the image of daniel 2 we see
satan trying to set up his kingdom
through different kingdoms you know
bible media persia greece rome and
that's why we see the image still
standing when the rock hits the image
yes although babylon had already fallen
as satan was trying to establish his
kingdom god has been trying to establish
his kingdom
since creation since uh the fall
but the spiritual kingdom yes because we
cannot have a literal kingdom before
having a spiritual kingdom so i would
say indeed in this sense the spiritual
kingdom
god maintains
this kingdom against all the power and
craft of satan
yes
his statement and and i think he is
conflating a couple
ideas
in the the in the days of these kings
is not
referencing the whole image yes it's
referencing the the iron clay kingdom
right at the at the feet
uh now did the rock
strike it on the feet and knock down the
whole image yes because the whole system
was destroyed yes but
uh if you follow the the typology if you
follow what is going on here
each kingdom has been succeeded
by another kingdom so that kingdom the
the preceding kingdom is no longer
uh on the field of action so babylon is
succeeded
through conquest through war by murder
persia succeeded by greece succeeded by
rome
so those kingdoms are off the scene of
action now we've got the ten toe
kingdoms and it is in the days of the
ten toe kingdoms that's right that the
the uh
image is destroyed but the whole image
is destroyed because satan's whole
system is is destroyed is taken over by
uh everlasting kingdom which will never
be destroyed so it's it's now and the
other part of this is and i won't forget
this is that um a knowledge was given to
the babylonians by the insertion of the
hebrew boys and daniel in particular uh
um which
uh
which assisted them but it wasn't it
wasn't
it wasn't
to the
effect of of the the
the rock kingdom
coming into play at that time that
didn't come in too much later i hope i
didn't confuse him
by my answer but you understand what i'm
saying yes that that that uh yes
one of the things that and ellen white
even tells us when when that little
maiden girl was taken by naaman
in the syrians god wanted to get the
word out yes you know and and he used
through
raids and capture right uh the getting
of the word out because israel should
have been doing that they weren't doing
that so god forced them into other lands
so that they would take with them a
knowledge of god a knowledge of the
coming christ a knowledge of the messiah
and the knowledge of their system so it
is true one of the ways that babylon got
the knowledge that nebuchadnezzar got
the knowledge which eventually saved him
was because
god's people were standing up for him in
a foreign land yeah and that and in that
way
god was teaching nebuchadnezzar about
and the babylonians about his kingdom
yes through yes his subjects here on
earth daniel and his friends well said
and it happened in every succeeding
kingdom you've got the the the days of
mordecai and in the whole thing you know
during the during the uh mutual persian
period and and each kingdom was was
given specific witness and of course
rome
had many uh and during
including the death of christ himself
during that time so um god didn't leave
any of those kingdoms in total darkness
he endeavored as he could to uh to bring
light to those kingdoms and of course in
the days of these final kingdoms the
image is destroyed
amen amen very good you know one more
thing about the kingdom is and is that
for a kingdom
to be established you need several
things
you need a king
[Laughter]
you need a city a capital city yes you
need subjects
you need a territory
and you need a law
and that's what christ has been doing
since he entered into the most holy
place right now he's being
crowned as the king
there is already capital city in heaven
yes
but the kingdom needs subjects
and during the investigative judgment
christ is choosing
who the subjects of the kingdom are
going to be very much so very much so
very true now the kingdom needs a law
that law has been trodden under foot by
the little horn the papacy
during the 12 60 years now god through
this remnant church the seventh-day
adventist church
god is trying to restore that law
and when that law is complete we restore
and all the world will have evidence and
light into
god's law and they make their decision
then the love will be established
forever that's why ellen white says but
before
uh shortly before the second coming god
is going to display the law before
everyone yes very true now the law is
established so now we will have a city
uh we'll have a king we have subjects we
have the law and the last thing will be
the territory yes after the millennium
god is going to renew that
this earth
and the heavens
and now finally
the kingdom will be established forever
yeah praise god actu actually you know
the territory will be without end we'll
have access to the whole universe amen
amen
we get everything
and we praise the lord for it but well
said daniel uh
uh uh that is a good way to look at it
and certainly uh that has been expressed
by god which is why uh revelation 22
tells us when he comes the reward is
coming with him you know he's gonna he's
going to bring his reward judgment is
going on now and it began at the house
of god and so we must live each day as
though
we are preparing for the last day
because when christ comes back he's not
coming back to make up his jewels he's
coming back to take his jewels back home
with him and present them to his father
so we praise the lord we praise the lord
for that
so we encourage you to
be part of this kingdom you know today
people are fighting for a
piece of land or an acre of land uh
inheritance and things like that but
when we think of what god has reserved
for us yes
that's something so small
in comparison with
the things
that the saints will inherit through
jesus christ so wonderful things are
awaiting those who are just those who
are righteous those who have christ as
their center so
we
remind you or we encourage you
to
be part of this kingdom through the
power and grace of jesus christ
keep sending your questions we really
appreciate getting these questions this
actually helps us go into god's word
deeper we receive a blessing when we
have to prepare
for this program because we can go
back to the word of god remember you can
send your questions to tv at some tv dot
o r g
and we'll try to answer these questions
in the order that we receive them god
bless you
stay well
and
i will see you next time blessings
[Music]
you